Глина — це, ну взагалі-то, щось рідне.
Таке, як колись Бог зліпив людину з глини,
так само і гончар робить собі виріб з глини,
потім як Бог вдихнув душу.
Так само ми його ставимо в піч,
випалюємо при високій температурі.
І так само даємо йому міцність,
життя йому даємо.
Чорнодимлена кераміка, чому?
Це вже як технологія випалу іде,
великий вміст заліза в глині
і коли в піч не даєш доступу кисню,
для горіння кисень вибирається з глини
і залишається чорний колір.
Вона нічим не покрита, просто лощиться.
— Камінцем.
— Лощиться камінцем.
— От,  виріб.
— Це є сирець.
Котрий сирець: відгончарений, поклеєний, висушений.
Тоді береш камінцем...
І от — це найбільш складно.
Коли він випалиться, буде вже такий блискучий.
От такий гладесенький.
Орнаменти беремо різні.
Але традиційні і для Гаваречинни, і для наших.
Оце для Гавареччини — пшеничка.
Нам потрібно було вивчити, які форми колись
робили з димленої кераміки і який був орнамент.
Потрібно було йти на базар,
на ринок, що ми і робили.
І щоб домовитися от так із людьми,
то я брала цінні, хороші, добрі
наші макітри нашого виробництва.
Міняла на їхні старі. Навіть маленькі шматочки.
Навіть такі малесенькі уламки.
І так з часом, ми з Андрієм вивчили трошечки
орнамент і форму Сокальського регіону.
Ми почали займатися керамікою у 1991 роцію
Молоді були, тільки після навчання,
тільки після технікуму.
Ми хотіли робити щось нове.
Коли ми вчилися на Гуцульщині,
було все дуже консервативно.
Ми вчилися в Косові.
— Я на металі.
— Я на кераміці.
Там і зустрілися в Косові.
Там і в 16 років почали зустрічатися.
— І так і одружилися.
— Потім ще армія.
Так, переїхали ми сюди.
Ми збудували будинок, майстерню.
І от почали робити.
Ми робили свистульки,
ми робили скульптурки малесенькі.
Нам так подобалося.
Ми їздили по виставках,
робили персональні виставки.
І ми показували, що не обов'язково
робити вжиткову продукцію,
можна ще щось і декоративне робити, творче.
Тут робиться глина, зберігається.
У кориті розмішується з водою.
Проціджується через сито.
Глина в рідкому стані.
І тоді вже...
Зливається у ванни, відстоюється.
Вода збирається.
Тоді вже на стрих
на літній кухні вже ставиться висушується
вже до більш твердішої маси і кладеться в мішки.
Не повністю ще тверді, так щоб вона..
Бо деяка глина може до року зберігатися.
Воно так іде собі процес відлежування.
А вже перед станком, там за тиждень, два,
то я вже собі досушую ще.
Взагалі-то в гончарстві дуже швидко
і легко можна видати ідею.
У тебе щось є на душі — ти відразу її видаєш.
Прийшов, поліпив.
У металі вже цей процес довше йде.
Ще в якійсь там архітектурі,
воно ще довше йде — ці процеси.
На деякі, як то кажуть,
шедеври світової архітектури, взагалі сотні років.
Сокальська кераміка була втрачена.
Тому, що за радянських часів її не розвивали.
Невеличка колекція лишилася.
Є в Сокалі музей Покотюка.
Є так само колекція у львівському
Музеї етнографії та художнього промислу.
І взагалі, вони видали цілу книгу.
Із тої книги і з тих майстрів...
Як я зробив форми, вони навіть почали
у мене вдаватися в пічці.
Мається на увазі, що менше браку.
Чому? Тому, що глина наша,
Сокальська, основна.
Як я робив інші форми, ніж гаварецькі,
вони багато тріскали.
Почав повторювати, от саме, Сокальські.
І в печі вони бували стовідсотковий вихід.
Місцеві майстри нашого району
тобі заочно так і допомагали.
Можливо й вони допомагають, а можливо,
дійсно, глина пристосована вже там століттями.
Бо той центр довго існував.
Все таки відпрацювалися ті форми ,
які виходили з місцевої глини.
В Сокалі там взагалі був великий центр.
Навіть історики розповідають, що більший центр
і більше майстрів, ніж в Косові.
Там була своя школа розписної кераміки.
Ми щось такі пробували,
але одинокий колір він більш гармонійний і якийсь...
Поєднання витворів, воно хочеться не кольором,
а саме формою.
Показати те, що ти хочеш показати,
що в тебе з душі йде.